so what are you doing outages are you
still dancing and stuff because you got
a bass yeah I started a month after I
gave birth so yeah it's crazy I was
waiting diapers and [ __ ] and stuff I'm
better than you are I started teaching
and they performed which is really funny
because when I was teaching her and tell
my students like you guys have no idea
like I'm peeing in my pants right now oh
you have do you have like bladder issues
after you have a baby and stuff I mean
it opened ten you know oh well I had no
idea
see that's the thing I don't know
anything about women body parts I just
learned about tampons
what tampons to be on one of the most
fascinating things I've ever observed if
I know well I didn't know what they look
like exactly because you just see the
plastic wrapping and then you see with
the aftermath of it in the batches right
and so I saw it with the actual
contraption which is pretty genius is
that plastic tube yeah yeah pick it up
you're your boobie Boppity and then the
honey and then you pull the plastic out
and it's just a little red tail that
sticks out you know a lot of guys don't
know [ __ ] about tampons but you know
Ellen and I started to have a
conversation about like the usefulness
of them because I only found out
recently how fascinating they were which
brands are crappy which ones are good I
got to tell you ladies you should really
be careful on your selection with your
tampons we did this experiment because I
was so curious I wanted to know about
pads right okay so I wanted to see how
exactly absorbent it is so I had my
friend Gio
we decided to test out pads and I use
all the girls all the girls at JK had a
different pet and I wanted to see how
absorbent they were really good test yes
turns out Playtex really good really I
use Playtex
boy but good you know why you need to
sponsor me is because other women talk
about tap but see here's the thing men
don't do it like I do we as men have to
go ahead and tell the woman's about
which ones we like so we could just go
ahead and I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
saying just sponsor me I need money
I had a friend long time ago that felt -
look there - and she felt so sick that
she had to go to a gynecologist and they
found - it's been a while
Ellen had some interesting stories I
kind of like the fact that she's very
open where she was telling about her
friend and her double tampon which is
[ __ ] disgusting I fail to understand
how you can leave a an object in your
vagina for that long and then shove
another thing up there
you nasty but give me the rats in there
because when you put in absorbent turns
into a manta ray it's like yeah let's
exactly what it is are you bad on your
period cuz girls get crazy
oh my god yeah I'm crazy alright I feel
it like a week before - it's always a
week before I'm always cranky
I call it the gauntlet it's called the
it's called the Kotlin because you don't
know what's happening for those you out
there who don't know a period is a
period in the month where a woman
transforms into a demon periods are
crazy like you also need like a certain
amount of fat in your body so that's why
you crave certain things and you eat
this kind of food or whatever because
you need a certain type of fat to store
in your body why the blood to hell I've
never experienced a period but I can
only equate like a certain terrible
scenario to imagine or put myself in the
shoes of a woman so I can kind of feel
what they're going through it's just I
call it the worst day on earth and then
your attitude reflects you know that
let's say me I just up I'm looking all
nice I feel good and then I walked out
there's a rain storm and I didn't like
the way I look at all Sun I ate some
mountain and the line under my mom
bloated I don't feel like the way I want
to feel and then somebody dented my car
but not so much where I have to get a
face that we have to go through
insurance but it's just enough where I
look at it and it bothers me that's what
I quit the period too
and he's irritated like the air bothers
you
my husband hates creepy for now because
I mean and my nickname in San Cisco was
called I was angry Korean okay cause
that's what angry man critical are the
most nastiest creatures and you know
what the way that gets Korean guys
actually like it but they hate it
because women who are also angry also
very passionate
they loved as hard as they hate exactly
I'm very passionate Korean girls are
super passionate it's a really good way
of saying I miss it that's messin the
all extremes extreme anger extreme
sadness extreme happiness they love you
hard but at the same time if you sleep
they will stick a kimchi knife in your
back
I don't even know what I can chew my
face I just made this [ __ ] up I used to
work at restaurants where my co-workers
would mess with food hardcore and it's
just so sad because it's true I would
never do it because I believe in karma
but like my friend hocked a loogie in a
mashed potato woman but I think the
reason why waiters do that because their
it they're forcing their karma onto that
bad person
so that's karma to them like because you
mistreated me this is karma coming back
at you so these papers I think so yeah
that's how karma is though right I know
Karma's
the universe whatever you put back out
will come right back to you
they just happen to be the enforcement
but I mean you would be the universe but
that's what happens like who's gonna get
who's gonna put the karma in them Jesus
I'm Carmen I became Karma when people
started [ __ ] around like you did me
wrong now I have to be mr. Karma that is
not it
no I have to you don't take the control
that's called revenge
yes is that what karma is yeah but karma
say what it was confident because I have
a complete what's karma you do bad you
get you you get something bad exactly
Allen's idea of karma is just like
everybody else's were you kind of stare
around and you wait for the whole
universe to balance itself but my point
is that you need somebody to balance it
so I am karma but let's say okay so
somebody did something bad to me I'm a
waiter right and then we say Karma's
gonna get them and then a different way
to spits in his food so that's karma
then yeah and that weight is gonna get
karma it's all caramel concept all
messed up right I like my sister well my
concept of what karma was is apparently
it's completely wrong cause in the car
she and I were talking about you know
basically what you give is what you get
and I personally thought karma was a
thing where if something's done bad to
me like for example let's say you
stepped on my foot it's completely
warranted for me to get a spear and
throw it in your eye you don't know what
karma is do you agree with me
thank you you're right in a sense he he
push you you push it back that's his
Karma but now you get comments that you
like keys your car hanging on karma and
then maybe you / is tired
so basically karma is saying that the
the world will balance itself yes you
just got to let it happen
yes oh that's so hard oh it's all right
that's very hard the best version of
karma is Korean Karma and basically if
you are Korean out there there's an old
Korean saying it goes if you hurt to me
pursed I heard of your right back your
mother pucker ships technique karma
Korean people work it doesn't work
thankful Karma